it can be easily undercooked or
overcooked here's how to do it properly
first water in nice large pan to make
sure the pasta's got sufficient room to
cook evenly nicely seasoned absolutely
crucial olive oil in
that stops the pasta from sticking
together bring it up to the ball
that's the rolling boil the secret there
it stops the pasta from sticking
together and it gently rolls it around
now this is angel pasta nice thin
pasta takes three and a half to four
minutes so into the pan
as it hits the water it melts and then
you turn it round tongs as that starts
to melt gently twist that into the pan
bring it back up to the boil if you're
bad at timing then set a timer
beautiful
to test it
lift a little strand
and you can actually feel it with your
fingers it's still nice and firm
al dente not a bite not a strong bite
but just really nice and firm inside
definitely not crunchy
and then
into a colander drain the pasta
in
a light seasoning
salt
and pepper
a tablespoon
of olive oil mix that through
that stops it from sticking together
and look
there you go beautiful pasta al dente
cooked perfectly
just as those carrots start going nice
and soft don't overcook them you want
that nice texture in there slightly and
just rinse
the rice
that stops the rice from becoming clumpy
in the pan